JASON SILVA: So we
talk a lot about how
we want the answer, right?
We're bliss junkies,
chasing the ultimate truth.
But think about it.
Aren't we more happy when
we're seeking the truth?
Aren't we all secretly
wonder junkies?
Isn't our addiction to the
question itself, you know?
Once you find the answer,
you risk completion.
You know, we talk about
wanting to find ourselves.
We talk about being found, but
isn't it more fun to get lost?
Aren't we all
wanderers, ultimately?
Aren't we wandering,
aren't we seeking?
Why do we love open spaces?
Why do open spaces
have more appeal
than beautiful,
cozy, small spaces?
Why do we look at
the infinite ocean
and actually feel a sense
of reverence and awe?
Instead of being
afraid, we look at it
as it beckons us to the
unknown, to the mystery,
to the question.
See, that's what it's
really all about.
That is the state
of consciousness
that we want to be at, right?
We want to be the traveler
in search of signification.
When you find, it's
over, you know?
it's not about the answers,
it's about the better questions.
You know that quote,
and that's really it.
That's what I'm looking
for in these spaces.
That's the JASON and the ring
landscape, New Zealand brochure
fantasy.
I'm getting lost in it, right?
Hm.
Only when we're
lost, we're found.
All right, guys, so
be sure to check out
our sister network, Seeker,
where we explore travel,
adventure, culture, and amazing
stories from around the globe.
As human beings, exploring
is in our nature.
We want to learn and
discover until we
are able to better
comprehend not
only the world, but ourselves.
What is without becomes within.